Idaho mom suspected of being involved in
the disappearance of her children
arrives back in her home state today to
face charges she's being held on five
million dollars bail since her arrest in
Kauai last month her two children 7 year
old Joshua valo known as JJ and 17 year
old Ty Lee Ryan have not been seen since
September Jonathan Vigliotti is in
Rexburg Idaho where Bala will appear
before a judge later today Jonathan what
are the people they're saying about this
case and good morning to you Gale
residents here in Rexburg Idaho knew
that this case turned a new chapter when
the FBI rolled here into town this is
their mobile command center it is parked
here behind the local police department
as they continue to collect evidence
lori valo will appear tomorrow before a
judge to face charges that include child
abandonment lori valo appeared before a
hawaii judge for the last time Wednesday
before being extradited to Idaho she's
facing several charges including two
counts of felony abandonment in the
disappearance of her children Ty Lee
Ryan and Joshua JJ valo
this is the first step in the courthouse
in Idaho which will trigger a cascading
series of events in the legal process
valo could face up to 14 years in prison
for each count of desertion of a child
her Idaho attorneys have filed routine
court documents asking the judge to
reduce her bond and requesting documents
and evidence from the prosecution just
tell people what's happening I have no
doubt that Lori Valley would love to
know what the FBI and any other agency
is doing in this investigation so what's
the easiest way to do that file a motion
for discovery and see if you can get
everything JJ's grandmother Kate
Woodcock is in Idaho for the hearing I
have total 100% belief that it's gonna
happen she's gonna be held accountable
100% for everything
attorneys for Lori's adult niece Melanie
pawlowski who's also faced questions
about the children's whereabouts say she
is now cooperating with FBI
investigators and has surrendered her
computer in addition to the case of the
missing children three mysterious deaths
surround
and her current husband Chad DeBell
including Valles previous husband
Charles valo her brother Alex Cox and
Chad's previous wife Tammy the
government may want to use this case in
order to get them to fess up some
information about all of those other
suspicious deaths and sources tell us
that investigators are now looking
through a trove of digital evidence that
could show a network of foul play
Alex Cox killed his brother-in-law there
is now the belief that he could be
linked to the death of Tammy de bel Cox
died in December Anthony before he could
be questioned all right Jonathan thank
you so much
you